welcome to phnom penh once known as the  pearl of asia this city was founded in  1372 and is known for both its  historical architecture and its bustling  food markets with over 2 million  residents in the city there is a lot  going on and that definitely applies to  the food scene  [Music]  first up a rice cake that's not what  you'd expect  [Music]  next a dish that caught our eye due to  the large flames  [Applause]  my  [Applause]  here is a dish that's sweet and savory  so it's kind of perfect  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  next up a street snack that looks a  little different but packs a lot of  interesting flavor  [Music]  m  and finally we saved our favorite for  last  seriously find this stand  [Music]  up  um  [Music]  [Music]  you